si vous êtes ici c'est peut-être que
vous faites partie des 50% des français
qui ont du mal à dormir il vous est
difficile de vous détendre avant de vous
coucher vous cogiter en pensant à votre
journée à votre emploi du temps du
lendemain il existe pourtant une
solution naturelle qui a fait ses
preuves depuis des générations
l'utilisation des plantes le fit aux
nuits en sachet à infuser un mélange
innovant de mélatonine l'hormone
naturelle du sommeil et de cinq plants
vous aide à vous endormir et bien dormir
alors ne pensez plus à rien et profiter
de cette séance de relaxation en
partenariat avec fit aux nuits le figaro
présente inspiration un podcast de
benjamin lubinski psy hypnothérapeute ou
youtube heures lors du dernier épisode
chez la chance de rencontrer guillaume
néry qui est un champion d'apnée était
plusieurs fois champion du monde d'apnée
la russie allait jusqu'à 129 mètres de
profondeur en une seule inspiration
évidemment et puis il arrive à tenir six
minutes comme ça on appelait statique et
évidemment c'est un vrai sportif qui
s'entraîne physiquement mais au delà de
l'exploit ce parti social exploit mental
il en faut du calme de la relaxation une
capacité est centrée uniquement sur
l'instant pour être capable d'affronter
ce réflexe est primordial qui est de
vouloir respirer et c'est amusant de
faire un parallèle entre les exploits de
guillaume néry et la pratique des lieux
guy qui pour faire en quelque sorte une
démonstration de leur pouvoir montrer
leurs capacités aussi à garder la
respiration pendant des temps très long
et ce qui m'a vraiment fasciné c'est que
son expérience est une expérience
psychologique intense quand ils
descendent dans les profondeurs de la
mer
il est complètement en méditation ils se
disent centré sur l'instant et quand il
revient il a une expérience assez
étonnante qu'on appelle la narcose où là
il est les prix de rêve à inconscient
d'hallucinations et c'est comme quelque
chose d'assez incroyable à entendre
alors ce n'est pas du tout là dessus et
qu'on va travailler on va travailler
bien sûr sur la détente ça va sans dire
mais pas du tout sur la narcose et
aujourd'hui on va travailler sur le
sommeil profond
parce que dans le soleil ce qui est le
plus important c'est ce qu'on appelle le
sommeil lent et profond
c'est là que vous allez récupérer votre
énergie
c'est là que votre système immunitaire
va se renforcer
c'est là que vous allez acquérir du
calme de la joie de vivre donc c'est
vraiment en fait c'est la partie la plus
importante du sommeil et ce dont on
s'est rendu compte grâce à un essai
clinique
c'est que l'hypnose permettait
d'augmenter la durée du sommeil lent et
profond donc c'est un sommeil de
meilleure qualité avec moins de réveil
et concrètement grâce au travail qu'on
veut faire aujourd'hui ne vous étonnez
pas si le lendemain vous allez vous
sentir déjà plus joyeux plus m
moins fatigués c'est tout à fait normal
le sommeil est primordiale et c'est pour
ça que je vous invite à le faire tous
les jours pour finalement non seulement
vous endormir bien ce que les séances
d'hypnose permettent de faire sans
difficulté mais aussi pour que votre
sommeil augmente en qualité et ça c'est
un vrai beau défi un vrai beau cadeau à
se faire que de se sentir mieux chaque
matin alors si vous êtes prêts je vais
vous inviter à fixer un point comme
d'habitude l'idée c'est de de se
focaliser sur quelque chose l'hypnose
c'est une sorte d'abstraction
l'extérieur serait dirige vers
l'intérieur dans une sorte de
recueillement est ce quelque chose que
tout le monde est capable de faire la
preuve c'est que justement si vous
faites un petit peu de de plongée avec
masque et tuba vous savez déjà qu'on a
cette capacité à s'abstraire et à être
fasciné être dans la contemplation c'est
quelque chose qui est très proche de
l'hypnose et puis ces moments quand on
est sur la plage aussi qu'on se fait
griller au soleil et qu'on oublie tout
jusqu'au temps qui passe mais ce sont
aussi des états de transe sauf que là ça
va être quelque chose de plus profond de
plus agréable et qu'il est vous détendre
suffisamment pour vous permettre de vous
endormir sans difficulté donc fixé ce
point regardez le avec un un regard doux
peu importe ce que cela veut dire pour
vous et puis prenez votre position de
sommeil celle qui est la plus
confortable celle qui demande le moins
d'effort celle qui est la moins
douloureuse si jamais vous avez des
douleurs et puis laissez vous porter par
ma voix comme si je vous racontais je
vous lise est une histoire et
aujourd'hui ça va être une belle
histoire autour autour de la mère et de
ses trésors cachés
et puis vous n'avez pas d'effort à faire
le moment vaut mieux se fermeront ce
sera peut-être aux chiffres simples
peut-être au chiffre 1 cela n'a aucune
espèce d'importance et plus vous
pratiquerez de jour en jour
cette séance de nuit en nuit est bien
plus vous arriver rapidement et
profondément dans cet état de cas mais
cela va jouer aussi en plus de
l'amélioration de la qualité de votre
sommeil cela va jouer sur votre capacité
à être calme
de plus en plus puisque votre frein
stress le système parasympathique va se
renforcer
et donc il n'y a pas d'efforts à faire
juste à vous laisser porter par ma voix
qui à certains moments bien sûr certains
mots vont vous échapper et c'est normal
c'est pour vous aider à
a lâché prise à décrocher 5
vous pouvez commencer à sentir
simplement parce que vous êtes
accompagné par ma voix vous centré sur
ce point ses couleurs sa luminosité vous
pouvez commencer à sentir cette
intériorisation que vous retrouverez de
plus en plus facilement de la même façon
vous pouvez la retrouver un certain
moment précis de votre de votre vie et
quand vous plonger dans un livre
quand vous regardez la télévision et que
vous oubliez tout autour quand vous
allonger sur la plage quand vous
rêvasser lorsque vous êtes dans une
voiture importe c'est un état naturel a
laissé quelque chose de très progressif
et c'est pour ça que votre respiration
devient nettement plus régulière et un
cran plus profonde plus landes
et puis ce sont aussi les sensations du
corps qui deviennent plus précises à et
cela fait partie d'ailleurs des choses
importantes quand on fait de la plongée
de l'année en amateur juste pour
s'amuser ou du maire professionnel c'est
que on passe dans un domaine j'allais
dire peut-être même à royaume où tout le
corps est en pro sensation puisque tout
le corps et et caressée par l'eau par sa
fraîcheur par cette tiédeur par ces
chaleurs parfois et la perception de la
troisième dimension la capacité à les
deux hôtes en bas augmentent aussi
l'impression d'être littéralement plongé
dans une réalité différente de celle que
l'on connaît habituellement et dans ce
dépaysement profond et bien il ya
certainement une partie du secret qui
permet
à cette pratique d'apporter énormément
de calme votre respiration commence à
devenir votre respiration commence à
devenir plus lente plus régulière grâce
à ce processus d'intériorisation et
j'aimerais que vous preniez deux
inspirations profondes comme ses
inspirations que l'on prend juste avant
de plonger quand on sait que l'on veut
vraiment d'un coup plongé littéralement
dans l'eau et le calme donc deux
inspirations très profondes qui vont
rapporter immédiatement un soulagement
une détente et après la respiration va
pouvoir tout simplement se ralentir
devenir plus régulière et pendant que
vous pensez s'accroche se décroche et
que certainement pas ceux des images de
ce que nous allons faire bientôt autour
des suggestions de la mer des
profondeurs et bien les pensées elles se
forment et se déforment forme d'autres
formes donc d'autres sous forte et vous
pouvez sentir cet air kahn ferait que
vous inspirez
et ce calme qu'ils installent de plus en
plus en vo comme de vraies de vraies
racines de calme
et lorsqu'un professionnel de l'apnée se
prépare avant de plonger
il passe par ces faces que vous êtes en
train d'expérimenter
il crée en lui cette capacité de calme
et la respiration sert à la fois à
renouveler ce qu'on appelle le volume
résiduel des poumons des recettes
quantité d'oxygène que nous gardons même
quand nous expireront mais aussi surtout
à à trouver le rythme et la lenteur du
calme et c'est ce que votre corps est en
train de faire il est en train de
ralentir pour plonger de plus en plus en
transe
mais le faire son rythme et dans la
douceur la tranquillité de cette
situation actuelle sans qu'il y ait
évidemment le moindre défi puisque c'est
ma voix c'est le temps qui passe et
votre respiration c'est votre corps qui
se détend c'est tout cela qui vous
accompagne de plus en plus entre ans
sans que vous ayez besoin de faire le
moindre effort
4 et c'est amusant de constater cette
apparition progressive de nouvelles
sensations
c'est cette respiration qui devient plus
profonde ne deviendra votre sommeil
cette nuit plus lourds comme le
deviendra aussi votre sommeil plus
régulier et le rythme de cette
respiration et puis on peut sentir le
poids des bras que pour des gens
cette lourdeur que l'on ressent lorsque
l'on est en dehors de l'eau et qui
magiquement presse que disparaît lorsque
l'on se retrouve dans une situation de
microgravité
dans l'eau poussé par cette loi car
chimed théorisé il ya de cela fort
longtemps mais là c'est encore le temps
la possibilité conjointe ou 10 juin peu
importe
consciente ou inconsciente c'est au
cordon de ressentir sa lourdeur les bras
les jambes lourdes le corps lourd pour
que l'esprit lys lèz flotte puisse même
peut-être rêvasser déjà ou à son rythme
cela n'a pas d'importance pour entrer de
plus en plus en transe et c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait progressive et
l'esprit lui ça les gens laissent au
corps la possibilité d'être lourdement
en transe et toutes les métaphores
toutes les sensations autour de la
lourdeur vont faire en sorte que votre
sommeil deviennent plus profond et vous
allez retrouver tout au long de cette
séance pour que inconsciemment l'idée
d'approfondissement s'installant vous
alors c'est pour ça que l'on prend là
maintenant le temps de sentir le corps
lourd poser lourdement sur le lit le lit
lourdement posé sur le sol le sol
lourdement posées sur les fondations de
cet immeuble de cette maison ses
fondations
solidement ancrées dans le sol sol
solidement ancré sur la ville et on va
plus loin l'imagination et un ressenti
la ville ancrée sur la terre la terre
solidement ancrée dans le système
solaire le système solaire est
solidement ancré dans la galaxie le
galaxy solidement ancrée dans l'univers
et l'univers solidement ancré dans le
temps le temps seulement créé en vous
tandis que vous on crée de plus en plus
en transe 3 cela me rappelle des images
magnifiques de guillaume néry des images
où il se trouve la tête à l'envers dans
l'eau et on a l'impression qu'il marche
sur la mer mais d'une manière inversée
c'est à dire qu'il reste dans l'eau et
que ses pieds touchent la surface de
l'eau et cela quelque chose de
profondément mystérieux et je ne sais
pas si vous avez déjà eu la possibilité
ou tout simplement remarqué cette
étonnante impression que l'on a lorsque
l'on est sous l'eau et que l'on regarde
l'extérieur glaire à travers l'eau c'est
là peut-être que l'on sent le mieux
la séparation entre deux mondes et cela
ressemble une sorte de miroir fascinant
qui déforme les nuages le ciel et crée
une impression tout à fait mystérieuse
et alors parfois celui qui s'exerce
s'essaye à la tenait du nerf simples et
quand il retourne son regard pour le
porter vers l'extérieur depuis l'eau
c'est à ce moment que les frontières se
trouble et que l'on ne sait plus
finalement à quel endroit on appartient
et quel est l'endroit sur lequel on se
sent le mieux
entre la lourdeur de l'extérieur et la
légèreté de la sensation marine entre
cette impression finalement de connexion
aussi de déconnexion paradoxalement et
cette impression presque d'être un autre
lorsque l'on est dans cette situation
différente en train de regarder notre
monde des formes et reformer dans cette
sorte de reflet d'évanescence côté un
peu éthérée de la perception d'un
ailleurs c'est comme s'ils ont plongé
dans un autre monde ou tout simplement
comme si on entrait en transe et dans ce
jeu entre la sensation que le plongeur a
cette sensation que l'on a d'être dans
un autre monde un autre monde parce que
la température ou simplement est
différente parce que le corps tout
entier baigner dans l'eau se sent pris
dans une sensation unique forte global
parce que la lumière est plus douce si
ce n'est les scintillements les rayons
de lumière qui traverse et qui se
diffuse d'une manière incroyable créant
bizarrement à la fois un sentiment de
réalité et 10 réalité il n'ya pas loin à
l'est pour percevoir quelque chose de
surréaliste quelque chose peut-être en
même temps de plus que rennes ou en tout
cas dans cette attention à la réalité
conjointe de deux mondes celui
primordial dont nous venons tous qui est
l'eau cette sensation que l'on avait
certainement lorsque nous étions dans le
ventre de notre mère
pesant rien de moins que le poids d'une
plume est ballotté par le mouvement de
la marche comme on peut l'être par le
mouvement de la foule où des vagues des
courants marins portés dans un monde où
tous les bruits semble diffus comme et
tout fait ce n'est pas vraiment le monde
du silence car l'oreille aussi peut
ressentir cet endroit mais c'est une
impression même de la sonorité de
l'espace du rendu de soi qui est
différente c'est un moment où la croisée
entre l'inconscient le conscient et même
le pré conscient et bien devient plus
significative plus particulière en cela
qu'elle devient en elle-même
l'expérience qui devient un
apprentissage qui est fou ce changement
qui ramène l'expérience de
l'apprentissage de cette différence mais
pourtant peut-être de ce retour
primordial au premier calme que nous
avons ressenti et même si c'est
peut-être simplement une image de penser
que lorsque nous pleurons lorsque la
tristesse sort de nous et que le
soulagement remplace cette émotion et
bien ce sont des gouttes d'eau salée que
nous avons et bien il ya quelque chose
se trouve de profondément symbolique
tout comme le fait de penser que au
départ dans le ventre de notre mère au
tout début et bien nous avons des sortes
de branchies qui apparaissent une
ressemblons drôlement un poisson en cela
que finalement les traces primordial de
nos origines lointaines
dans le mouvement d'évolution darwinien
le plus simple et bien finalement ces
traces archaïque reste en nous et nous
avons finalement la fois une distance
vis à vis de l'homme et en même temps un
lien très profond et tout à faire
anciens un lien que nous pouvons très
facilement retrouver dans la transe à
mesure que vous entrez et profondément
30 alors que vous pensez s'accroche et
se décrochent s'accroche se décroche
alors que vers ce faisant se faire
naître rien d'autre que ce que l'on
s'est fait alors même que vous savez
toujours plus que vous ne saviez que
vous saviez 1 et il est temps maintenant
de laisser vos paupières se fermer si
elle ne l'était pas déjà et de laisser
la douceur de ma voix et le calme de
votre respiration approfondir cet état
de transe cet état de gamme auquel nous
aspirons tous et que nous retrouvons
dans la plongée au contact de l'eau et
c'est certainement pour cela que pendant
les vacances nous sentons ce besoin
souvent impérieux de se baigner de
retrouver le contact avec cette chose
qui en nous nous pousse nous conduit
nous appelle nous invite aussi et nous
présente en tant que tel en nous mêmes
mais pour le même parfois même par nous
mêmes non pas sur une sorte de pressenti
de pressentiment
en cela que pressentiment et la chose
pressenti non pas ce besoin
continuité non pas le besoin de se
rejoindre en quelque sorte la même
manière que les limites floues entre
conscience et inconscience préconscient
entre ce que l'on peut appeler aussi en
fonction de sa formation et de sa
manière de voir le monde surtout
inconscient mais surtout le mois le ca
le surmoi tout cela comme finalement de
simple représentation mais au delà de
simples représentation est bien une
réalité de l'expérience une réalité du
ressenti une évidence vous entrez de
plus en plus en transe et pendant que
vous pensez se font et se défont se
rejoignent ce repère finalement d'une
certaine manière dont ce que l'on pourra
appeler presqu'une une destinée mon tout
cas une prédestination peut-être tout
simplement une destination cela dépend
du regard de l'imaginaire que l'on
construit du développement et c'est
intéressant de voir comme le corps et
luo profondément lourd alors que
l'esprit lui s'allège dans la transe et
de cette dissociation c'est à dire d'un
côté l'esprit allégé qui rêvent allégée
du poids du conscient bien sûr allégée
en soi même léger par la sensation même
d'allègement de légèreté peut-être
retrouver en quelque sorte le caractère
essentiel de ce qu'est la rêverie le
corps lui lourd profondément lourds qui
va s'endormir d'un sommet lourd profond
tout aussi lourd profond et calme que
l'aide plus en plus votre expérience de
la transe qui progresse en vous c'est
donc dans le jeu conscient ou
inconscient peut-être dans cette manière
que l'on pourra avoir de considérer que
la conscience sont des terres émergées
et l'inconscience les océans le maire
est finalement l'inconscient recouvrant
la plus grande partie du globe et
pourtant cette partie la moins connue la
plus mystérieuse qui pourtant au centre
de toutes nos ressources de tous les
changements et d'un point de vue
métaphorique ce n'est peut-être pas si
étonnant que cela que ce soit le berceau
de la ville au l'origine de tout
l'origine de l'évolution l'origine des
espaces et l'origine finalement de la
vie sur terre
alors lorsque l'on plongeon soit lorsque
l'on plonge dans la mer ou l'océan et
bien on se dirige forcément vers quelque
chose d'essentiel de primordial c'est
très bien
maintenant je vais demander à votre
inconscient de vous faire imaginer une
très belle plage en polynésie c'est
l'endroit où guillaume néry passe une
partie de l'année pour s'entraîner
certainement se reconnecter une très
belle plage déserte et peu importe si
vous y êtes déjà allés si vous n'avez de
ce plh que le souvenir presque d'une
carte postale d'un documentaire on a
tous en nous finalement cette idée
presque le tony sienne cette idée d'une
plage parfaite idéal que le sable soit
jaune presque blanc ou qu'il prenne
d'autres teintes peut-être noir
peut-être plus rouge que le ciel soit
parfaitement bleu où qu'ils soient
peuplés de petit nuage pommelé que cela
soit le matin au lever du soleil ou en
journée lorsque le soleil chauffe
agréablement les corps et apaise les
esprits ou le soir lorsque tous
retrouvent encore plus de tranquillité
que le natural même semble se reposer ou
peut-être même la nuit lorsque lorsque
cette plage cet océan se retrouvent
illuminé
à la douce lumière des étoiles à la
lumière presque tendre tout pâle de la
lune
peu importe le moment de la journée
l'important c'est que cette plage idéale
va pouvoir se préciser en vous et au
delà des images je parlais à l'instant
laissons les sensations elles vont se
préciser
c'est très bien peut-être débris
d'oiseaux des bruits d'oiseaux exotiques
peut-être des oiseaux plus connu le
bruit des vagues peut-être le grincement
des palmiers qui se balancent gré du
vent peut-être le bruit de votre propre
respiration toujours plus profonde et
plus lente
c'est aussi les sensations la sensation
du contact de l'air la sensation
peut-être de ces deux petites gouttes
d'eau porté par le vent et qui se posent
parfois sur le visage c'est peut-être le
contact du sable
c'est peut-être le contact show du sable
au contraire c'est étonnant de fraîcheur
dès que l'on creuse un peu plus profond
et je vais vous inviter à tout
simplement vous asseoir et contempler
l'océan a essayé de percevoir au loin de
la barrière de corail comme une sorte de
protection comme une sorte de mur qui
vous permettrait de rester dans un
univers parfaitement paradisiaque que
cela soit la plage et lille où bientôt
la barrière de corail blacks ont observé
et laissez votre esprit inconscient tout
autant que l'esprit conscient plonger
dans la contemplation et dans cette
connexion qui vient très vite lorsque
finalement tous les divertissements
disparaissent c'est à dire la présence
d'autres personnes
un livre un téléphone
à jeu et l'activité lorsque l'on
s'autorise vraiment à s'asseoir et à ne
rien faire
au bout d'un moment vous retrouve une
vraie connexion c'est quelque chose que
vous pourrez expérimenter dans votre vie
même dans des paysages et des situations
bien moins paradisiaque
même dans des situations et des paysages
bien moins paradisiaque aujourd'hui de
temps en temps s'offrir le luxe de ne
rien faire de méditer de contempler
c'est quelque chose de précieux dans la
furie du monde et dans l'attention de
stress de nos journées c'est si facile à
faire lorsque l'on prend le temps tout
simplement le temps
et que l'on coupe les divertissements
pour se plonger en nous-mêmes à mesure
que l'on contemple davantage à cet
instant même et pour vous le paysage la
mer la barrière de corail loin on peut
sentir à quel point l'inspiration
devient profonde lente car il est temps
maintenant de vous diriger vers cet
océan
les progressivement doucement pour
passer sans violence de ce monde
extérieur ce monde intérieur
prendre le temps de sentir la tiédeur
agréable de l'eau qui pourtant apporte
une certaine fraîcheur
paradoxalement sentir cette impression
qui progressent le long des jambes à
mesure que l'on s'enfonce dans l'eau
tout doucement et que l'on sent le poids
du corps disparaître au fur et à mesure
le même manière que nous ceci semble
s'alléger disparaître ce n'est pas
étonnant si dans les religions souvent
par la pollution se nettoie avec l'eau
pour quelque sorte se purifier c'est
bien cette sensation que l'on a lorsque
l'eau se pose sur nous c'est comme si
elle nous l'avait détention faisait
disparaître pour permettre de se
connecter à quelque chose de plus
précieux et de plus profond
continuer tranquillement lots progresse
sur le corps avec cette sensation très
particulière de sentir que des jeunes
corps est connecté à la mer elle a vu le
visage les parents cas c'est déjà un
pied dans chaque monde et prenez une
simple inspiration
profond pour rentrer d'un coup dans
l'eau et vous laisser plonger dans un
univers différent plus silencieux dans
un autre monde et les soucis
disparaissent simplement parce que vous
entrez dans cet autre monde plus profond
le cas et bien sûr sans qu'il y ait le
moindre paradoxe puisque vous êtes
centre ans dans la transe 12 de
l'hypnose
votre respiration pourra continuer sous
l'eau et continua sa profonde et
à mesure que l'expérience de la transe
sera plus profonde
les oc elle préfigure à se se met de
plus en plus profond qui vous permettra
demain d'être si léger si bien
[Musique]
un peu
c'est un peu cela la nuit le soleil
c'est comme cette césure
ce vin que l'on prend
cela c'est par deux temps
tout va permettre se sentir régénérer
calme nouveau se sentir ressourcer
elle a maintenant que vous êtes sous
l'eau
j'aimerais que vous preniez un rocher
tout
[Musique]
au contact
simplement pour vous maintenir sous
l'eau
et que vous preniez le temps de vous
asseoir
sur le sable
à quelques dizaines de centimètres ahmed
peut-être de distance de la surface
et l'a pareillement que j'aimerais que
vous preniez le temps
de la méditation le temps de ressentir
en même temps qu imaginé et vivre le
contact de cette pierre d'être
intérieurement vous asseoir en tailleur
et vous laisser porter par la houle par
cette sensation de légère d'être balancé
part peut-être le mouvement des vagues
des courants et pourtant de plus en plus
fixe de plus en plus calmes et
profondément créés grâce à cette pierre
que vous partez
[Musique]
c'est très bien
et comme guillaume néry dense et très
joli film je vous invitais marché sous
l'eau a marché
sur le sol
[Musique]
j'ai marché
comme si vous découvriez un univers tout
nouveau quelle sensation merveilleuse
que de marcher sous l'eau
d'avancé
et d'observer
la nature observez ces poissons couleurs
presque métallique chatoyantes
presque holographique
dans les couleurs bleu jaune rouge
orange semble encore plus profonde
encore plus vibrante
la couleur des papillons là bas de
l'autre côté
il ya la beauté des algues
ces algues dit parfois vont chercher les
dizaines de mètres de profondeur le sol
pour y enfoncer leurs racines et se
diriger ensuite vers la lumière
la roue
peut être observé quelques jolis méduses
totalement inoffensif bien sûr
observer
ces animaux qui ressemblent à des fleurs
des anémones de mer
observer
l émissaire
qui traverse d'une drôle de manière la
surface des flots et c'est comme cela
avec ses rayons de lumière que mon père
soit vraiment la réalité des photons de
ses traits de ces lignes de lumière qui
traverse l'univers
c'est aussi ressentir simplement
le contact de l'eau la caresse de l'eau
cette formidable sensation de liberté
puissante
profond qui s'ancre toujours davantage
en vous
observer
la réaction des à nouveau à votre
approche
certains qui prennent la fuite d'autres
curieux qui se rapproche de vous
et même si le monde et même si le monde
sous-marin est inconnue est la plupart
d'entre nous il existe sous l'eau des
espèces très intelligente et parfois
très tous de caractère les mérous par
exemple qui se laisse facilement
apprivoiser
des aussi des poulpes et pieuvres
qu'ils font partie des animaux les plus
intelligents
peut-être aurez-vous la chance de
creusez un devin par exemple
[Musique]
août observé
le vol merveilleux d'une tortue soul au
gala nage pas elle vole la même manière
que les rêves vol d'avoir l'an magie
cieux
et la tique
et vous êtes n'est pas si à chaque fois
que vous replonger dans ce type noz des
animaux l'expérience change c'est normal
c'est votre inconscient qui à chaque
fois ont tissé une trame différentes
pour vous amener vers ce noyau essentiel
en vous de gamme de sérénité de
profondeur que la transe et préparer
ainsi le sommeil récupérateur lourd et
profond de la nuit
vous avancez
et bientôt vous pourrez
voir la barrière de corail
[Musique]
vous allez pouvoir la franchir
simplement
en laissant retomber cette pierre
pour d'un coup avec une merveilleuse
légèreté vous remettra vous dit
et profitez-en pour garder
cette barrière de corail j'allais dire
cette terre nourricière en quelque sorte
ce foyer intense de vie
endroit où nichent les poissons où ils
pondent
l'endroit où toute une nature
merveilleuse se sont protégés vie se
développe croix
et en même temps
ce secret dans la nature
cette beauté
il pourtant
correspond pas ce que darwin disait
la beauté ne sert pas survivre ne
devraient pas être choisis par la
sélection naturelle et pourtant
tous
dans cette barrière de corail rayonne de
beauté
vous connecte à quelque chose de
fondamental
presque trente ans
reviens ou hors du lien dans cette
manière de ressentir
finalement
d'aller au delà de la réalité simple
pour qu'une atmosphère de beauté de
sérénité toute entière s'imprègne en
vous
je vous invite à dépasser cette barrière
un moment vous pouvez voir
que la mère tombe à pic une sorte de
falaise
et je vous invite à cet endroit
apprendre à rocher et comme un apnéiste
simplement plongé à la profondeur de
l'océan
vous allez descendre tout doucement
pourrez regarder la surface qui
s'éloigne
le corps qui s'alourdit à mesure que la
douce pression de l'eau s'imprime sur le
corps et la vide s'alourdir plus
profondément dans la transe dans un
sommeil de plus en plus beau fond votre
sommeil sera de plus en plus profond à
mesure que vous allez plonger de plus en
plus profondément
toujours plus profondément cette douce
obscurité
cette douce tranquillité
qu'apportent les fonds marins
[Musique]
vous descendez toujours davantage
de l'autre côté de l'expérience dans le
lit le corps toujours plus calmes et
l'eau voir sa respiration s'approfondir
davantage un disque de l'autre côté le
corps lui aussi plus loups en esprit et
dans l'expérience de l'hypnose plonge
plus profondément vers ce noyau
essentiel vers l'inconscient vers cette
sérénité puissante
[Musique]
où tout le superflu s'efface dépensé
laissé loin derrière la surface
on progresse de plus en plus lourdement
vers le centre de soi même le centre
profondément de plus en plus
profondément de la même
et l'on peut même fermé les yeux encore
une fois mais cette fois à l'intérieur
de soi même pour profiter pleinement
pour profiter pleinement de cette
sensation douce de cet approfondissement
de la transe ko profond de plus en plus
en semences et vous allez pouvoir
continuer
cette expérience allait de plus en plus
loin chaque nuit dans une relaxation de
plus en plus profonde qui ouvrira la
porte d'un sommeil de plus en plus
profond et récupérateur
ne vous étonnez pas si à certains
moments alors que vous sentir le corps
tout entier intense remontera en vous
des images de journée plus douce plus
joyeuse et plus calme des journées
passées étaient journée futur
plus tôt ce plus calme et plus joyeuse
grâce à un sommeil plus profond et plus
récupérateur
dont vous continuer à descendre et ma
voix simplement servir d'arrière fonds
d'accompagnement doux
tranquillement
[Musique]
en cela qu'elle parlera à la fois au
conscient
la condition
pourquoi maintenant alain permanent
cette sorte
de jeu croisé entre le mois et de ça
dans le sommeil profond de la transe les
yeux fermés toujours plus en transe
[Musique]
comme une sorte de deux guides
silencieux
la fois invisible par tous les présents
partout également
mais
dans ce murmure presque
cela la voix devient une sorte de
musique tout s'accompagnant l'expérience
de la transe
[Musique]
pour la lenteur est même perçue
ressenti regret accompagner dans cette
plongée inconscient du moi profond
l essentiel toujours dans cette manière
de
se diriger bien sûr
en soit pour soit par devers soi parfois
silence qui vont bientôt venir
[Musique]
pour que la nuit silencieuse soit encore
plus profonde
et le sommet et rêvent plus doux
conscient se délester de tous pour
plonger toujours plus profondément
oubliant t'oublier d'oublier
et qu'on se vend
recevant percevant la fois l'essentiel
et le profond
les profondeurs justement de la mer
l'océan
de soi
toujours plus toujours davantage
toujours plus avant dans une relaxation
profonde qui était simplement à la
respiration lent de l'autre côté
la voix douce en arrière plan
dans cette lenteur du moins dans la
conjugaison des expériences d
apprentissage
ce que
chacun
lui-même peu par lui même le dépôt
lui-même aussi sans qu'il y ait besoin
de début de 20
cela que le temps se disperse plutôt se
reconcentre dans une expérience globale
non pas comme une dimension
supplémentaire mais une perception
intérieure d'un flux
du nom d'une variation
comme une sorte de musique
non pas pour les oreilles mais pour
l'âme peut-être l'inconscient sûrement
l inconscient déjà depuis longtemps
partie
dans ce que
la mémoire
souvenirs l'imaginaire le rêve de soi
mais aussi une expérience
intime secrète profonde de la réguler
dans la régularité
[Musique]
de ces instants
2 c'est maintenant
du souvenir
peu distant chaque instant
finalement être soi et soit totalement
profondément
cette plongée et multi vas les
profondeurs
insondable de l'aide
on se réalise tout changement
toute renaissance toute évolution
[Musique]
dans cette conception elle même plus ou
moins fluctuant
présente le
défini aubin
[Musique]
consultez peut-être
perçue certainement
développer toujours
dans leurs rêves profonde sommeil
profond les lourdeurs du corps et d'une
respiration tout aussi profonde comme la
transe profonde et les profondeurs de la
mer des océans
toujours plus en soi
de l'armée
profondément
l'avortement
lentement
ce mail plan
les profonds
je n'ai en place
déjà dans semaine
l'inconscience est qu'il peut vous
offrir
de plus en plus de ce mail en est
profond
pour ressentir toujours plus calmes
heureux
ce sera
sept séances de bien-être vous a été
proposé en partenariat avec le fit aux
nuits le fit aux nuits en sachet à
infuser un mélange innovant de
mélatonine l'hormone naturelle du
sommeil et de cinq plants pour
s'endormir et bien dormir
bonne nuit avec le complément
alimentaire vittoz nuit